because i know like you guys have been
saying how much you want to go up to the
north right yeah i really do i really
really
really want to go in the winter because
it seems like really a lot of things
happening in the winter oh yeah i wanna
i wanna hit up the onsen
in the winter that's gonna be so nice
yeah just trying to get naked
i just wanna get naked we haven't talked
about onsens on this podcast
publicly haven't seen your guys's dick
so much now that i don't even question
it
going to the onsen with you it's like
you start
the first time we used to like first
time went to the onsen together i was
like oh you gotta
but now it's just like whatever we're
getting naked with the boys another day
with the boys but like i feel like a lot
of people
are afraid to go to onsens for the first
time because
because of that barrier right yeah you
just have to be naked in front of the
boys i mean in a lot of countries it's
not very normal is it yeah some people
have been like yeah you want to come to
the onsen with me
and you know they that immediately
they're just like no i don't want to do
that
yeah and they're like oh because i don't
want to get naked and i'm like it's just
that
like it wasn't even like a decision it
was like in the head it was like of
course it's no i'm not getting naked
yeah
yeah but it's like but everyone around
you is nate yeah yeah it's like you're
not gonna be the only one that's naked
it's like most european countries
right everyone's naked yeah right yeah
but that's surprising though isn't is
that like i've
tried to convince so many of my european
friends to go on onsen because
in my head it's just like oh bathing
together is like a very normal thing in
europe in a lot of european countries
right so i'm like oh well if it's
normal in their country and their
culture then must be easier so yeah so
many times i'm like hey you want to go
to the onsen they're just like no
i think i don't know maybe like our
generation it's like less of a thing
than it was
like 20 years ago yeah yeah in the older
generation because i remember trying to
convince my cousin to go to the onsen
when he visited japan yeah
and it was just it was just like
breaking down layers
right so first i'm not just i'm just
like yeah it's kind of it's kind of like
how can i like because he's the biggest
norm you can imagine right so how do i
explain the
cultural significance of like an onsen
and a hot spring to someone who has
never watched an anime
this is the same cousin that watched the
live action at taiwan yes yes
and like he's like seven eight years
older than me so he's from like the
older generation as well so
had to be like okay so it's kind of like
a hot tub
but it's like a public hot tub yeah and
he was like oh yeah
that sounds fun you know so he was like
oh yeah yeah
so it so you wear like a bathing suit
and everything right
and i was like okay so here's the thing
here
you just everyone's naked and you know
every
and that's it's just a really relaxing
experience and it's a really cool
experience and his voice tone just like
completely changed
just oh yeah oh
oh i'll know about that one chief
because i love how you had to go in such
a roundabout way it wasn't just like a
yeah we get naked it was like well
i mean we have bathing suits we just
take them off yeah yeah yeah
you just take them off yeah you can wear
bathing suits until you enter
yeah yeah because what was the first
onsen experience for you guys like
because i remember you guys yeah i think
it was when we all went
with uh i think it was us three and
allen yeah
yeah in the uh dance and in uh yeah
odaiba yeah i'm pretty sure which is
like a massive it's like a super cent or
super concern as it's called but
and i remember the fact of like knowing
that we're going to get naked in front
of each other
that was just like i i think i just
built it up my mind so much because i'm
just like
oh it's it's about to happen i mean it's
about to happen i mean i remember that
day like we all
stepped into the onsen yeah and alan was
like all right lads whip them out
let's just get it out of the way let's
just like let's just
get on the table get the meshes out just
gather around in a circle
and we'll just look at each other's
sticks and then just be
over it and we're like all right three
two one all looking good like okay we're
good
no one's popping a fat all right we're
yeah and then it just literally took
five minutes and then i was like
completely comfortable
and then it was an amazing experience
and i feel like people who are
so afraid to go over that barrier are
missing such a good
experience it's an experience you can't
really get anywhere else i feel like
even i've been to kind of you know
public uh you know bathing places in
europe as well but this just
yeah i don't know it's just i don't want
to say it it's different but
you know it's there's something that's
not quite right there's the vibe
it's just different yeah yeah it's
definitely like vibe check you know
onsen check constant check yeah bruh
i don't think we have public bathing
places in europe do we but we have like
the saunas which uh
it's kind of similar right i guess yeah
you don't really bathe together you just
get in the sort of naked and
some people are like you know they'll
cover themselves i don't know because
for me it's not just the onsen
experience it's like
everything around the entire experience
like
getting out of the onsen when you're
like especially in the winter sitting
out in the ons in a public onsen
when it's like really cold or sometimes
raining and
i've heard when it's snowing it's
amazing as well yeah
like that's like i've heard it's like
proper anime whether like there's mist
and everything yeah yeah
i want to experience that one day but
after coming out and having that
drink of cold milk yeah that's like the
most refreshing
hand on the hips hand on the hip so what
do you do you have to like put your hand
on your hip
drink the milk in one and it's like the
most refreshing glass of milk
but it's like vibe right you gotta do it
and then having like an izakaya beer
afterwards is just
[ __ ] incredible yeah i just it makes
when you're in an onsen for some reason
it makes you want to just be a ceo and
talk business
like i don't even have business to talk
about but i'll be like gentlemen let's
discuss
the topic at hand like animated
it just makes you want to talk about
important things with three other people